cínico bárbaro sacado del libreto de
jugadas rusas es la feroz desestimación
por parte de occidente los documentos
que según moscú son la prueba de que
eeuu estaba llevando a cabo un programa
de armas biológicas en ucrania la casa
blanca desmintió el jueves las
afirmaciones diciendo que el kremlin
estaba creando un falso pretexto para
utilizar sus propias armas químicas de
ucrania
rusia también tiene un historial de
inventar mentiras descaradas como esta
que es la sugerencia de que eeuu tiene
un programa de armas químicas y
biológicas o que ucrania lo tienen
el presidente de ucrania volodymyr es de
la inc y dijo a rusia que tendría que
rendir cuentas y utilizaba armas
biológicas contra su país bien ya que en
mi tierra no se ha desarrollado ningún
producto químico ni ninguna otra arma de
destrucción masiva el mundo entero lo
sabe y si rusia hace algo similar contra
nosotros sentirá en respuesta el peso de
las sanciones más duras posibles
pero aún no está claro cómo respondería
el mundo el ataque con armas biológicas
por parte de rusia la casa blanca no
quiso declarar esa medida como una línea
roja y volvió a descartar cualquier
posibilidad de que los eeuu pise terreno
ucraniano te llevas los militares
estadounidenses vayan y se comprometan
en ucrania y luchen en una guerra contra
rusia no tenemos ninguna intención de
hacerlo ciudad el consejo de seguridad
de las naciones unidas se reunirá el
viernes a petición de rusia para debatir
sus acusaciones sobre la presunta
implicación de eeuu en un programa de
armas biológicas en ucrania